what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so this is one of the best Batman
stories that I have ever read like
Batman White Knight is insanely good and
I've been saying that since like the
since this first issue came out like the
first issue came out I checked it I was
already hyped for it because I was like
dude this looks cool and I was reading
the solicitations and all that kind of
stuff and I was like okay I need to
check this out so I was already excited
then the comic gets released Shaun
Murphy is the one who's writing it I'm
just like dude this is incredibly good
it's it's insanely good all right so so
what this does is this picks up about
one year before the present day now what
did it bear in mind is that Batman the
White Knight is not in continuity maybe
this has no ties to DC rebirth other
than the fact that is published at the
same time that DC's doing DC rebirth it
may be that because this is such a
high-profile and such a popular story
that you'll see it later on down the
line but for right now you can just
imagine this this story is totally
isolated and takes place in a whole
different universe and what's going on
in DC Comics right now but this picks up
about a year before the current day and
it's just a stereotypical Batman Joker
conflict that is kind of chasing after
each other Manson nature a Batman and
Joker right I mean they're kind of like
the yin and yang because of the fact
that this goes in your stereotypical
fashion of a Batman Joker escapade it's
basically like just running throughout
the entire city of Joker like Batman's
chasing Joker over rooftops things like
that Joker's riding a scooter I mean
that's really about it it's kind of
silly and it's kind of nonsensical but
something I want you to notice is that
Batman seems to be going to extremes and
he seems reckless here I mean right off
the bat this does not seem like
something we would normally see Batman
do so the indication is that Batman is
in a state of desperation but he's got
Batgirl along side along with him he's
got Nightwing riding on a motorcycle
that man's doing things like again
riding over rooftops crashing into
cement trucks with the Batmobile all for
the purpose of like trying to find the
Joker he's basically like disregarding
virtually all safety protocols now once
Batman catches up to the Joker again
it's just kind of a at least it seems
like a pretty straightforward fight but
for the most part the Joker just kind of
leads Batman into this sort of ruse
where he just kind of you know is like
Hetch me if he can find me so on and so
forth well the fight is pretty intense
and it's pretty hardcore because what
you end up having here is in this battle
the Joker actually makes this really
interesting case to Batman and what he
basically says is that they are created
to be the same thing what they stand for
is designed to be the exact same thing
you know Batman stands for love the
Joker stands for hate they're kind of
like in this interesting you know yin
and yang intertwined scenario the
cuz one can't live without the other but
when Batman's facing off against him
when he's literally like wrecking the
Joker what Joker says is he led him to
this location with all these cops
following with Barbara Gordon and with
Dick Grayson watching all this unfold
and he brought a bottle of pills and
these pills that the Joker says if I
take these then I'll finally be able to
show you everything that I see and what
the Joker sees is a city that's
basically sick and the Joker believes he
can fix it and so where Batman and his
recklessness grabs the pills he forces
them down the throat of the Joker and
this is crazy because the entire thing
had been recorded by a member of the
press which in turn was publicly leaked
and this is where things really begin to
go awry because what you end up having
is the city of Gotham which is kind of
split in half on one side you have
people who say yeah I mean the Joker
took the lives of others but the Joker
still has rights ie if the Joker goes
through the judicial system and the
Joker is found to be not guilty then
it's okay to sacrifice future people
because the Joker deserves to live the
people that he killed don't really
matter here whereas you have other
people who say no the Joker killed
people he deserves to die no questions
asked and so you very much have like
this huge rift within the city of Gotham
and it stems in every conceivable way I
mean Batman beat the Joker to a pulp so
you literally have Batman on camera
beating the Joker within an inch of his
life and enforcing a handful of pills
which no one knows what they will do
down the throat of the Joker you have
the police department fighting amongst
one another the same rift exists here
that's the question I would pose to you
guys this is Joker still have the right
to stand trial or did he did he
basically abandon that right did he give
up that right when he willingly killed
so many people that's the question I'm
kind of asking you guys where do you
draw the line how many lives are you
willing to sacrifice before you finally
say enough is enough
The Joker can't kill anybody else
anymore that's the kind of scenario
that's being put here to the city of
Gotham and that's the kind of question
that I'm putting to you guys but what is
up happening is where Commissioner
Gordon initially takes a side of Batman
says look sure Batman's done shady
things sure Batman has has broken the
rules or bent the rules in order to
basically get the criminals but at the
end of the day he drops them off on our
doorstep he gives us the evidence and so
what that does is it throws them in the
hands of the justice system so they
still go through the entire proceedings
it's just the manner by which they were
caught may have been a little bit
illegitimate but at the end of the day
Commissioner Gordon's concern is not
necessarily for the Joker it's for what
happens next and so what we do is we get
the
brief little panel where the Joker just
wakes up in a cell surrounded by Batman
paraphernalia something else also want
you guys to notice too one of the
posters here is actually from Batman the
Animated Series which is really cool so
kudos to DC for throwing that in it but
what we end up doing is picking up with
Bruce the one he's met with the arrival
of Dick Grayson and Barbara Gordon and
again they recognize the fact that
Batman is acting pretty extreme here now
again under normal circumstances we
would look at this and we would say this
is not how Batman works
he's clearly written out of character
here but this is when we start to get
the other side of the equation this is
where we realized that we've basically
been jumping to conclusions the entire
time without ever really knowing what's
going on and so picking up with Bruce
Wayne when he leaves Barbara Gordon and
Dick Grayson down into the basement of
this building we end up finding out that
Alfred is basically dying and he's been
this way for about a month and so
Bruce's recklessness the fact that he's
going to such extremes aints taking such
a heavy hand when it comes to villains
is for a couple different reasons one
because he's forced to work with one
with mr. freeze to basically put Alfred
on ice until a cure can be found so that
he can be brought back from whatever's
killing him and then at the same time
he's literally stressed and desperate so
he's been pushed to his wit's end and
he's just kind of at this point where
enough is enough and that's what led to
him being so extreme and so at this
point we jump back to the Joker and this
is when things get really cool one thing
I want you to notice here is as Shaun
Murphy doesn't really give us like a
traditional origin of the Joker we know
his name is Jack Napier from like the
original 1989 Batman movie but this is
cool because what he does is he sits
down and says it basically he was raised
on a farm like he was not really raised
in Gotham City proper but he was told
Gotham City is like this city of lights
and so it's very much a tale of
discovery like the Joker is a stand-in
for like Oliver Twist for example
leaving the workhouse leaving the The
Undertaker's taking off saying I'm gonna
go to the totem the City of London the
great big city in the sky you know
coming across a kid named Jack Dawson
Jack Dawson says his name's the Dodger
he takes Oliver to meet you know mr.
Fagin and then ultimately Oliver's
trained to be a pickpocket realizing
that London's not everything he thought
it was until he meets mr. Brownlow
that's the whole thing about this the
Joker believes like almost everybody
believes the land of lights the land of
Lala you know for LA this idea that if
he goes to Gotham City he'll have this
better life he tried to get into comedy
but the biggest problem with Gotham was
that it was a city that was so lost it
was a city where the people had given up
to such an extreme that no one could
ever really find any happiness there it
was quite literally a city of sorrows
and so what the Joker do
that in turn he tried to get a rise out
of people and turned to terror turn to
crime and became the Joker that's really
kind of how Jack Napier turned all this
but the whole idea is that when he
basically turned to a life of crime
he discovered Batman Batman was able to
instill in the city of Gotham some small
measure of hope that the city of Gotham
could be better than a place that was
just run and dominated by criminals and
the result is that the Joker saw a
Batman was doing able to get a rise out
of people in such a fashion and begin to
somewhat identify with him in the sense
that they both ultimately had the same
goal they were trying to make the city a
quote-unquote better place the
indication here is the Joker's message
was lost in the conflict and Batman's
wasn't but regardless of how all this
goes down what we end up doing is
picking up with downtown Gotham City
only for us to find out these pills he
read that he had taken had basically
made him sane
they made him a reasonable human being
he's not crazy anymore he hasn't lost
his mind anymore instead what goes on
here is that when the evidence is
brought to those in power they're
basically told he's perfectly reasonable
like his mental health is at 100% and
where questions are asked as to whether
or not this is possible if he's faking
it the answer that's given is you can't
fake a cat skin this is legit the Joker
is normal and so when the other question
is asked what's he doing right now the
answer is he's working on his legal case
he's going to file charges against the
Gotham City Police Department Batman and
Gotham City he's literally taking
everyone to court and so what we end up
doing is picking up with the Joker when
he's met with the arrival of Gotha the
Gotham City Police Department who
actually try to try to implement some
pretty underhanded tactics petrow to
like force him in a position to where he
has to accept responsibility for his
actions but notice this this is what's
so genius about this The Joker sits down
and the Joker says I'm not guilty of
anything I'm not guilty of anything at
all every ounce of destruction that took
place in this scenario was because of
Batman it was Batman who's driving an
unlicensed weaponized tank it's Batman
who was driving it over rooftops it was
Batman who injured three people when he
hit a cement truck
it's Batman who knocked over a guard
it's Batman who almost beat me with
he'll beat me within an inch of my life
and it was Batman who forced pills down
my throat I was riding a scooter and I
hadn't actually killed anybody what you
as Gotham City Police Department have
done is you've sanctioned a vigilante
who's taken the law into his own hands
and then in turn said we don't see a
problem here but it's only now that
somebody raises a red flag when somebody
blows the whistle and says actually
there is a problem
and I have the legal case to prove it
that suddenly you want to step up and
you want to try to apply some
underhanded tactics now when
Commissioner Gordon steps in and he
basically says no no no Batman is not
the Gotham City Police Department he
does not speak for us The Joker's
responses actually he does because you
have a bad signal and that bats analysis
on top of the Gotham the Gotham City
Police Department building and you use
it whenever you want to get a hold of
them you sanction this man Gotham City
has failed the Gotham City government
has failed at stopping crime you as the
Commissioner of the police department
and your Police Department have failed
at stopping crime Batman has failed at
stopping crime you guys are basically
pointless here and so if you won't save
the city of Gotham if you won't get off
your asses and do what you're supposed
to then I will I will save the city of
Gotham game set match so the writer
Shawn Murphy is probably gonna go down
as one of the greatest Batman writers of
all time and it's stuff like this that
makes you want to see like things beyond
this yes why I love those guys who don't
know DC's playing it really really smart
when it comes to DC rebirth Marvel kind
of has the stance of like is it a story
somebody can write then like give it an
ongoing series that's kind of Marvel
stance it's one of the reasons why
they're publishing like 60 comic books
but DC has this I had this idea of just
doing like miniseries and that's it DC
is running like like five or six Batman
miniseries of the moment like sins of
the father and all these really really
cool stories when it came to like
Nightwing the new order it was just like
a different take on the Nightwing
character or things had basically gone
awry and that's what I love about this
is because what it does is it gives you
this amazing story at least you know the
white knight does it gives you this
amazing story and then it kind of
answers the question so what if we
expanded this out to like the bigger DC
Universe so like Shazam and the Justice
League and like all these different
characters and all these different
things what would it look like and like
that's the cool thing about this cuz
like it makes you want to see more but
in the last video we talked about how
Batman had basically like gone crazy
tracked the Joker down forced a handful
of pills down his throat and ultimately
the Joker became sane as a result of
those pills and the result was the Joker
while he wasn't heard by the police
basically came up with this like this
argument that like the cops have
systematically helped the Batman become
a vigilante that they're part of a
bigger problem now what that problem was
was something that the comic ended on it
was basically the Joker is Jack Napier
back to his normal self essentially
saying I will bring light to this
problem I will show the city of Gotham
what
really are and so that was the question
that I saw in the comments from a lot of
different people
if the Joker has had this life of just
killing arbitrarily and robbing folks
and doing all kinds of crazy things even
if he was on trial he would just get a
life sentence and that's it but this is
the beauty of the judicial system is
that at the end of the day it's not left
to a judge it's not left to like a cop
it's left to a jury
all the Joker has to do this convince a
jury and the opinions in the wants and
desires of the cops and the and the
lawyers and know Batman and the judge
they're all irrelevant and really like
Jack Napier does this in the smartest
way possible if you want to win anything
you have to win the people for the most
part the people are the ones who decide
what happens in a court of law it's no
different Jack Napier basically sits
down and says this is my city I came
here as an immigrant for the most part
like I came here from from a small rural
farm willing to make a better life for
myself and when I got here I realized
that life was hard and life was rough
and like anybody who made bad decisions
I turned to a life of crime and and I
screwed up once I was busted and I was
sentenced to 10 years what I began to
realize was that crime is a product of
the police in Gotham because what the
cops were doing is they were basically
using existing criminals and turning
them into like super villains and then
using them as a means to keep crime
going and it's the greatest idea of a
conspiracy because if there's any one
thing that people loved it's believing
that like there's some great you know
some hidden hand out there controlling
everything behind the scenes even if
there's none but in terms of desperation
people will believe what they want to
believe and they'll simply ignore facts
if there are any at all and so the
result is that he basically sits down
and he says look at the city of Gotham
for what it is like look around you and
look at what it is what you see are the
wealthy prospering you see the poor
struggling and you see Batman fighting
the poor it's kind of Jack maybe you're
twisting up the facts to a degree but
it's also like providing a pretty
interesting image the Batman is not a
vigilante trying to keep Gotham safe
that Batman's not there to like protect
the people Batman's there to protect the
wealthy from the people and it's so cool
because it's like what better way to
turn the entire city of Gotham on Batman
than to basically say like he's not here
to protect you he's here to protect the
wealthy and the powerful from you it's
the Joker in a lot of ways inciting
revolution in the city of Gotham it's so
cool
half of this is like how he feeds on
words for example there's a part of
Gotham City called backport which is
really where like a lot of minorities
live specifically african-americans but
the popular phrase to use is black port
and that's why this is cool because it's
turning all these things on the city of
Gotham itself it's criticizing the press
who are complicit in in the vigilantism
of Batman and in the actions of the
Gotham City Police Department it's the
Gotham City Police Department who's
complicit and basically the creation of
crime in Gotham and the profiteering of
crime is all these things that go on
it's so cool because he says look like
anytime anybody ever asked the question
but where's all this extra funding going
to like what are you doing with all this
extra money where the police department
was using it to create villains when
people started asking too many questions
well oh no the Joker's escaped we have
to get the Joker guys it's such a cool
way to portray the city of Gotham is
just crooked and corrupt and so what we
do is we pick up with Jack Napier when
he gets back to his house and he's met
with Harley Quinn right off the bat it's
him trying to relate to Harley Quinn and
we would kind of expect this but at the
same time we wouldn't hurly Quinn has
always been in love with like the Joker
as a person like how the Joker manifests
himself and how he treats her is just a
byproduct of the relationship but it was
always like her obsession with him she
would follow him to the edge of the
earth and she would do whatever it is
that he wants her to do because she
believes that she could like somehow fix
him or turn him around or get him to
love her it's the quintessential like
good girl in love with a bad boy
all the while never realizing that she's
just one of many women that bad guys
been with but where he starts to talk
about things like proposal and marriage
and these pills and so on and so forth
she immediately freaks out and starts
attacking him but while this is
happening were suddenly met with the
arrival of another Harley Quinn and I
was like what in the hell is going on
here as soon as I saw that I was like
Sean Murphy Sean Murphy man you you
genius but then as soon as I look at it
I'm like okay this looks like the
original Harley Quinn and that's when we
find out that it is that this is
actually the original Harley Quinn and
this is this younger version of Harley
Quinn that exists out there at the
moment is not the actual Harley Quinn
and this is kind of funny because what
we find out is the original basically
left the Joker and a new one took her
place the Joker just never really
realized it he never knew what was going
on now this of course leads into like
the obvious question how could the Joker
not know that like Harley Quinn took off
and replaced her you know replace
yourself with somebody else and it's
kind of cool because Harley goes through
and tells her story and this is what I
liked here's what I loved about this so
much is this like Shawn Murphy
all these different aspects and all
these different themes of Batman's
history with regards of different
characters and sort of rolled it all
together into a version that we're
familiar with but has changed just
enough to just kind of make it like a
wholly unique and separate line of
events and much like the main the main
DC Universe when it comes to like Harley
and when it comes to this version of her
character as she fell in love with Jack
Napier as he was the Joker but for her
it really wasn't just like man let's
just let's just be crazy it wasn't like
she just snapped one day for her it was
an escape it was the idea that like like
her life was boring and it was mundane
rinse and repeat her life is is by
definition as she sees it completely and
totally mundane but the Joker
represented a change from that the Joker
was random he had no idea what was gonna
happen next and it gave Harley Quinn the
the belief that she was free from the
shackles of society I mean sure they
were vigilantes they were on the lam but
the fact remains that she could do
anything she wanted to there was no
limits to what she could do the world
was her oyster and she wasn't
constrained by like societal standards
and lost but as time began to progress
and when Batman first showed up she
began to notice that the Joker's
affection that his obsession switched
from Harley Quinn to Batman and that he
basically was in love with the idea of
Batman every thought that he ever had it
was all about Batman and Harley Quinn
began to fade further and further into
the background and because of that like
it gave her no desire to want to be with
him anymore but all this came to a head
when the Joker kidnapped Jason Todd now
again this is almost kind of like Shaun
Murphy's twist on the death in the
family storyline when like the Joker
basically killed Jason Todd like it's
kind of a kind of a twist on that idea
but were Harley Quinn's there she
basically kind of runs up and says look
you're going too far but notice this
this is not insane Harley Quinn this
isn't the kind of Harley Quinn that were
used to where she just snapped one day
the Joker drove her insane
she's very sane she's completely and
totally rational she's like a regular
normal human being but the Joker
basically went too far this time it's
you can't just run around and kill
people not only that is predicated on
the idea that like the Joker was jealous
of Jason Todd because Jason Todd was the
right-hand man of Batman how come I
can't be the right-hand man abandoned
how come I can't be that close to Batman
well then I'll just kill Jason Todd
because I'm so angry that he's in that
position not where the the implication
was that Joker had killed Jason although
were not explicitly told that was the
case
man tries to kill the Joker and Harley
quit actually stops him and says you
can't kill him
and so Joker basically went back to
Arkham Asylum and that was really about
it but this is cool because what she
basically says is like sure I mean you
know these these pills kind of help you
to maintain this sort of loot you know
this lucidity but like like Jack Napier
recognizes the Joker's still in there
that's still very much a part of who
Jack Napier is but the stance of Harley
Quinn is you can be fixed but you can be
set back to normal and so again that's
why I love this so much is because it's
the Harley Quinn concept as we know her
without the insanity that we're familiar
with that's what ultimately jack
basically sits down with her and says
yeah I guess we can sort this out I
guess we can get this going but the
funny thing about this is that this
almost you know switching over to Bruce
Wayne when he meets up at a dinner party
it hits it this idea that Batman didn't
really know the impact of what it was
that he was doing he was blissfully
unaware of like the full totality of his
actions and the reason why I say this is
because there's basically a guy here
named Pierce who's kind of a dick and
basically has been you know been
drinking alcohol the whole time so on
and so forth but where you end up having
a Jack Napier and Harley Quinn jump on
TV and saying like we're taking this
settlement money and we're opening the
first library in backport and the result
is that Pierce basically starts talking
to Bruce Wayne about like the nature of
things what he says is that inside of
backport really inside of gotham you
have were to call that impact zones and
what this means is that when Batman
shows up in an area and starts fighting
crime and of course damage is done it
absolutely tanked the value of the
property
well what wealthy people are doing is
they're going in and then buying up all
that property flipping it and then
selling it at a premium and so they're
basically making money off the work of
Batman and this light this pisses off
Bruce to the extreme but it's kind of
funny because it's like how could he not
know this how could a man who's one of
those like the richest person in Gotham
really have no idea that people are
doing this either it means that Batman's
incompetent as a superhero or Batman's
die genuinely just didn't know but
either way like it is it is really cool
because basically it means that like the
Joker was not lying
Batman was an enforcer for the rich and
the powerful and Gotham and so from here
you pick up with Jack Napier in Harley
Quinn basically meeting with a whole
bunch of different villains now the cool
thing about this meeting between the
Joker in these villains is there's a lot
of really really good at Easter eggs in
here this is this is this is
how you know that like Sean Murphy is
like a Batman fan because like there's
these little Easter eggs for example
there's one point where Killer Croc says
it so it was a big rock now this comes
from Batman the Animated Series or
anybody who remembers Batman the
Animated Series back in the day and it
was an episode called almost Gotham
which is exactly why the what Jack
Napier says is like every time we talk
it turns into a game of almost scout
that episode was was amazing it was cool
because it's basically God if I remember
correctly it's the Joker Killer Croc
poison ivy and two-faced I think maybe
even the penguin sitting around in a
poker game telling the story of how each
one of them almost got Batman and Killer
Croc is like yeah man like i lured
Batman into a sewer and they were like
yeah like and then and then what
happened he's like I threw a rock at him
and like they all started looking at him
kind of funny and he's like I mean it
was a big rock you know but it is cool
because what you have is the Joker
basically say a really jack maybe you're
basically saying look we should
consolidate our efforts in order to
basically take the city of Gotham back
we have to work together if we're gonna
bring down Batman now because of the
fact that each one of these villains is
for the most part used to operating on
their own they basically give the most
expected answer which is not a chance we
do our own thing like we we we don't do
that like we do our own thing we commit
our own act that's basically what this
is and so what we end up finding out is
that what the Joker had done is actually
taken I guess what Jack Napier did I
keep wanting to say the Joker what Jack
had done is he had basically taken
Clayface and he had used one of the Mad
Hatter's on controlling cards along with
the controlling head man meaning he had
complete and total domination over
clayface's mind and then what he did is
he started turning Clayface into a kind
of like salt or sand more or less and
then began dispersing that among like
the various strengths that he had inside
this meeting and so what's been going on
is all the villains who were here
they've been drinking this offering from
the Joker all the while not realizing
they're actually ingesting the ability
for Joker to control them and that's
exactly what happens by this extension
Joker has single-handedly taken over the
entirety of the criminal underworld
inside of Gotham City okay so normally
we would have done Batman the white
knight on Wednesday but we covered Dark
Knight's medal and so we're covering
this today but this will come back like
next week we'll cover on Wednesday like
I prefer to keep this every week on a
Wednesday that way you guys can expect
to you know see the videos come out but
this is continuing to be just such an
amazing story and it's such a cool story
because the Joker is so smart like I
love the way
this is done by Sean Murphy the whole
story so far is that Jack Napier is
basically gone saying that Joker's turn
into a sane human being and has decided
that it's basically his responsibility
to conquer the city of Gotham to
basically take it over using the will of
the people and that he's essentially
ensnared the various villains you know
poison ivy and in Bane and two-face and
all these different people using the
power of the Mad Hatter basically
slipping all these people mind-control
nanomachines ah the Mad Hatter uses and
in turn doing it through two-face
feeding them drinks and then controlling
their minds using the actual headband of
two-face but it's cool because what this
does is this opens up basically with
like all the villains of Gotham just
launching an attack on the city of
Gotham itself and of course it requires
the entire bat family to respond at this
point it really only consists of like
Batman Batgirl and Nightwing Dick
Grayson and that's really about it so
it's pretty short as it is now they also
have the police who were fighting on
their side but what is up happening here
is you have all these different villains
who are basically rampaging across the
larger city of Gotham with Batman
heading to backport which is where you
know a handful of them are somewhat at
and where initially Commissioner
Gordon's idea is we all have to head to
back court we all have to help out that
man at the end of the day Bullock and
and even other people like Renee Montoya
are just kind of like no no no no Batman
can handle himself we need to focus on
the larger problem in in the main Gotham
City itself now of course what this does
is it kind of puts in a strop relief the
idea that Batman's willing to go to any
lengths to take down the Joker and it
almost makes Batman look like he's not
looking at the big picture because what
is him happening is he basically says
like the Joker's behind this we have to
find the Joker you know we can go to
back port we can take these guys out
they're not going to destroy the library
the Joker just built there's no way
that's gonna happen but it does and
again it's brilliant here because the
Joker when he went saying he basically
made the case that Batman does
everything he can to take down villains
with no real thought to the collateral
damage Valon doesn't care about who gets
displaced from their homes when
buildings are destroyed
balle doesn't really care about how much
it cost to rebuild things when he
destroys stuff
all he cares about is getting the bad
guy and this fits directly into that
notion because bein in Killer Croc start
tearing down the library but to
everybody who's watching all this unfold
Batman chased down a couple of villains
quartered them and they freaked out and
destroyed a building it's Batman's fault
that's how people will see it that's how
they will perceive it now Batman runs in
there and basically tries to
these guys but gets caught in you know
all the destruction and everything only
for like two-faced and Killer Croc to
basically have gotten away so Batman is
perceived as being single-handedly
responsible for the destruction of all
these different things now at this point
we switch over the two Joker himself to
Jack Napier and we end up finding out
this was exactly what we thought it was
it was just a distraction his idea was
to basically wait until the smoke
cleared and then go to the Law Offices
of Hill and Hill the former Law Offices
of the current mayor Hill in Gotham City
and what he does is start sifting
through all these old files
he starts sifting through all this old
information all these little secrets and
things like that that are not supposed
to be readily known now what we end up
finding out is a reason for this is
because he basically goes in front of
national television and he says what you
guys don't know is that like people are
profiteering off of you every single
time Batman ghostified a villain money
has to be spent in order to fix the
buildings that he's destroyed in order
to repair the roads that are damaged or
whatever the case may be and the
question that that that Jack Napier
presents here the Joker presents here is
where does this money come from who's
spending the money to do this and this
is what he basically makes the
announcement of what's called the Batman
devastation fund that unbeknownst to all
the people in Gotham that what's been
happening is exactly what we discovered
in the last video that you have this
kind of tax payer relief fund more or
less that taxes have been increased or
whatever the case may be
there's kind of a disaster relief fund
that exists out there but because
there's no real natural disasters in
Gotham this is a ruse it's a way for the
wealthy to essentially funnel taxpayer
money into the Batman devastation fund
and then as we discovered in the last
video what they do is they basically
repair these buildings and then that
drug that you'll when when that man
destroys an area it drives down the cost
of everything so the wealthy can
basically repair these buildings improve
on them dirt cheap and then sell them at
top dollar they're using taxpayer money
to basically charge taxpayers more money
for the houses they have to buy or buy
back in order to return to where it was
that they were when Batman destroyed
everything and so again it's pretty
heinous what Jack Napier is doing is
he's sitting down and he's revealing
kind of the truth he's basically showing
the man behind the curtain in the city
of Gotham and saying your city is
rampant with corruption like you
wouldn't believe
now this is big because let's say for
example that like this sparked a
revolution in the city of Gotham and
let's say that like the government and
the wealthy they basically like bring in
the National Guard well the National
Bart has brothers and sisters and
mothers and fathers and sons and
daughters who were just the people of
Gotham and I would bet all the money in
my pockets - all the money in your
pockets that if it came down to those
police officers and those National
Guardsmen and National Guard's women who
have been set on the path of trying to
quell this revolution but if they have
to make the choice between pointing a
gun on the wealthy and the powerful who
caused all this or putting a gun on
their own friends and family don't point
a gun on the wealthy and powerful and in
that moment it would come into sharp
relief the idea that the wealthy and the
government have no power and that's the
cool thing because once that goes away
once that that line of defense vanishes
then suddenly it's open season it's
really really interesting it's a way for
Jack Napier to win the people because
that's all you ever really need now at
this point if we pick up with Bruce
Wayne of course return him back to the
Batcave kind of fixing himself up and so
on and so forth but then Alfred wakes up
when Batman basically collapses and
because of this what is up happening is
Alfred actually removes himself from
wherever it is he's been healing from
inputs Batman in his place this is cool
because what this does is it actually
kills Alfred Alfred basically sacrifices
his life in order to heal Batman now in
truth Shawn Murphy doesn't make this and
like a great big huge like one shot
right it's not like a brunt of the story
because it doesn't need to be a great
big huge thing because we know it's a
huge thing Alfred dying for the sake of
say of saving Bruce Wayne is insane and
is huge Alfred is the moral compass of
Bruce Wayne if Alfred's not there
Batman will just run a ride there'll be
no one to reel him in when he starts to
cross over that line that he's always
tried to keep from crossing over and so
what happens is you have Dick Grayson
you have Barbara Gordon you sit down and
say it's up to us we're the ones that
basically have to hold Batman back and
keep him from crossing over and losing
his mind in its entirety something else
that I want you guys to notice too and
this is this is a pretty cool moment
it's actually one of my favorite moments
of the story Shaun Murphy shifted things
up in a pretty and a pretty amazing and
interesting way here while Barbara
Gordon and Dick Grayson are at the
cemetery basically you know paying
paying their respects to Alfred there's
a tombstone there for a Jason Todd now
our initial response would be Jason Todd
was killed by the Joker you know you was
basically beat up with a crowbar and
then blown to pieces and Batman didn't
get there in time and so on and so forth
no no no that's not what happens what
Shaun Murphy actually tells us is that
Jason Todd was Robin before Dick Grayson
and that's
huge it's cool like it's really really
cool to me that's why I like these
stories that are kind of out there is
because to me telling the same
chronology all the time gets really
really boring and really mundane and
shifting things up just enough to make
them different is actually really really
interesting to me because Dick Grayson
doesn't really know anything about Jason
Todd all they know is that Jason Todd's
death kind of set in motion the reality
of the fact that you can't save
everybody that Batman couldn't save
every single person that mattered but
from here what we also do is pick up
with another little bit of a change and
we basically have the Joker who shows up
in backport and actually meets with Duke
Thomas now Duke Thomas is grown he's a
grown man in this instance and again
this is really fascinating to me because
Duke Thomas in the main DC line of
comics is young I mean he's basically
the signal I mean it's Batman and the
signal we don't really know exactly what
he's gonna be but we know he's not going
to be a Robin we're just kind of waiting
for his character to be fleshed out but
in this story he's grown he's fought in
the military you know he's basically
like Special Forces for a while he's
kind of like the guy who doesn't really
trust Jack Napier but he's somewhat of
the tour guide here because what Duke
says is that I don't necessarily trust
you but backport loves you because
backport views Jack Napier as the only
guy who's on their side they view him as
the only guy who's willing to help them
out and again this sets in stone the
idea that the Joker's hitting all the
right marks that he's getting all the
right support from all the right people
now what this also does is this hits of
the idea that Jack Napier could make a
run for like mayor and basically become
the mayor of Gotham and he would have
the vote support in order to pull it off
and that's again where you start to back
people into a corner and so what we end
up doing here is we actually pick up
with a woman who basically breaks into
the facility of the Joker sort of but
not really but she basically comes
across the Mad Hatter and of course you
know the Mad Hatter is spouting
different things like you know Alison
Wonderland quotes and so on and so forth
which is what he does but this woman
who's actually not the Joker's daughter
thank God as soon as I saw this I
thought it was like the return of
Joker's daughter from like the new 52
and I was like oh man I really hope not
them there were a lot of people who
hated the idea of Joker's daughter The
Joker's daughter was designed to be kind
of a stand-in for like Harley Quinn
in the new 52 he was an attempt to
basically replace her and even kind of
replace the Joker to a degree and give
us like a new version of the Joker or
something along those lines I have no
real idea what the purpose was and that
was evidenced in the fact that she just
kind of floated
and there was no real story to be told
about her she was kind of interesting in
the beginning but then after that you
know people were just kind of like no
give us the old Joker which I'm glad we
did because we got Scott Snyder's Joker
who was insane but this girl breaks into
the facility only to find out that
basically like Clayface is being
controlled with a car - the Mad Hatter
that's been slipped inside his brain
which it's kind of cool to see the
interior of Clayface once he like turns
to dust and fades away and it's just a
brain with eyes attached to it which I
guess still works at me I don't know how
it's getting oxygen no clue anyway so
this chick is it's cool because she
basically like like the Mad Hatter
spills the beans and says everything
that's going on here is being done by
Jack Napier Jack Napier runs everything
no idea what it isn't what do what he's
gonna do with it but Jack Napier is
basically running the entirety of the
criminal empire but this is huge because
what this means is that Jack Napier
Secret is no longer a secret if the word
is out now that Jack Napier is actually
the one behind the scenes pulling the
strings when it comes to all the
different villains in Gotham City okay
so we are continuing our story on Batman
the white knight and I'm glad you guys
are really enjoying this I'm glad you
guys are really really diggin the white
knight because it is such an amazing
story it's crazy the next comic book
convention that Shaun Murphy goes to I
want to sit down and just be like all
right dude how did you come up with this
idea I want to just like have a
conversation with a guy and just be like
man I will buy you lunch and just tell
me how you came up with this idea
because this is this is awesome like I
really really want to do that
yeah this story is so cool okay so
here's the thing Batman the white knight
cuz I was talking to comic story about
this and and it was one of those things
where I didn't really occur to me until
I was reading it but it is very much a
political story but the cool thing about
this is that it's a political story done
in a really really good way because what
it does is it creates kind of a you a
unifying factor with readers as opposed
to like a political story that focuses
on race relations more so than anything
else basically we have Jack Napier who's
kind of running the show like Jack
Napier who's basically elevated himself
to prominence in in Gotham City after
having quote-unquote cast off the Joker
identity but the cool thing about this
is that within the realm of Gotham City
within this whole area you have back
port and back port is largely where or
african-americans reside at and so with
Jack Napier showing up here initially it
does kind of put on the play of it being
like a sort of race-based story like a
racial political story and this is that
Jack Napier has appealed to the four
black parts of society that live inside
of Gotham City but where Duke Thomas
kind of like the the speaker for this
part of Gotham City for back port it is
cool because he basically says look like
the cops never come out here we're kind
of just left to our own devices to try
to make sure that things don't get too
terrible the cops are never really out
here the wealthy never come out here
Batman only ever comes out here to
remind us of our place to make sure that
we don't get too far out of our little
pocket of the city but no one ever
really cares about what happens to back
court and then Jack Napier came here
with no security he came here with no
cops no escort no nothin it was Jack
Napier and Harley Quinn who just came
walking into back port that right there
is brazen enough because it's kind of
like look we could be killed at any
point just because of the fact that
we're politicians and were perceived as
part of the wealthy elite that are out
there were enemies of backport more or
less but walking in there is a sign of
Solace because it's like look we realize
we're putting our life on the line
walking in a back port but that's the
risk we're taking because we want to
make this part of Gotham a better place
and that's what Jack Napier has been
doing he came there to build a library
he's been helping to improve the youth
center like he's been gaining the trust
of Duke Thomas over the course of the
time that he's been there and we know
been working within back port and
because he's gained the trust of Duke
Thomas and everyone in back port trust
Duke it means now they trust Jack Napier
Jack Napier in turn basically uses this
moment to announce his candidacy as a
councilman in Gotham City and this is
where Shawn Murphy initially kind of
Dell's into the idea of like racial
issues and then immediately jumps to the
bigger picture and says okay now it's a
social class issue because throughout
the story the entire time we learned
about things like the Batman Fund the
sense that you have Batman who goes into
a part of town things get destroyed the
value of that property plummets the
wealthy buy it the government uses the
the Batman neo destruction fund or
whatever it is to rebuild that area and
then the wealthy sell it for top dollar
they basically profit off of Batman's
actions and the the criminal element of
Gotham City when you have Jack Napier
who steps in and who in turn says like
this issue stretches all across the city
of Gotham suddenly it's not a racial
thing anymore because poverty is
race-neutral and if you're Jack Napier
and you can walk in to the city of
Gotham if you can turn over a new leaf
and then say I want to fix the city of
Gotham and I want to do it by getting
rid of all the corruption by making
Gotham a better place by starting with
the poor and making your lives better
you've just won an entire social class
it's Jack Napier winning Gotham City not
by force as the Joker but through
politics is Jack Napier so from here you
basically have him like leading a march
and that's when all this really kind of
be kind of begins to take off and it
really hits home with the idea that like
Jack Napier is really gonna do this you
know he starts as having people marching
in different directions the cops are
going to respond and then Batman
intervenes and keeps things from getting
out of control
but Batman is already viewed in a sour
perspective by the city of backport so
for everyone watching this for everyone
out there for everybody in in backport
who's watching this event unfold
everybody who's watching from TV what
they see is this back port is a city
that has been historically oppressed
within the realm of Gotham poor black
Americans live there Batman is routinely
sent there to keep them in check the
wealthy and the powerful profiteer off
the struggle of people I'm in back for
it and then when as soon as you have a
person who crops up and says let's make
this part of the city a better place
Batman comes swooping in you know that's
how people see it they basically see it
as like this system working against the
people of backport and they don't care
what politician runs form and
recognizing what's going on here Jack
Napier tells everyone to stand down so
there's another everybody stand down
everybody chill relax calm down I'll go
willingly suddenly he's the good guy
he's the guy who saved back port and
that's exactly what happens it picks up
with Gotham insider and they basically
say like we thought there was gonna be
another riot and back port but Jack
Napier swoops in and saves the day when
the press wins social media when the
people in the city and who cares what
the wealthy and the powerful want to do
because they're powerless in the face of
millions of people who don't want them
there and could just drag them into the
streets and shoot them if they wanted to
so again it's cool it's such a twist on
the character of the Joker now from here
we pick up with Jack Napier meeting with
Commissioner Gordon I remember
Commissioner Gordon has been the one cop
who's been on the fence he's been the
man on the wall in the Gotham police
department not in the sense that he's
like the only guy out there keeping
things afloat but in the sense that like
he's the one who's not really sure what
direction to go in because remember
Commissioner Gordon has always basically
been a good guy he's done some
questionable things but he's usually
always been a good guy he was the guy
who said look we don't necessarily like
the idea of a vigilante in Gotham but we
do realize that we need Batman because
he's willing to do things that we as
cops can't do but Commissioner Gordon
has always been on the fence about
Batman and he's always been on the fence
about his role as a police commissioner
and the corruption in Gotham City and
Jack Napier plays on that but him
showing up and talking about the Batman
devastation fun and things like that he
says look I want to use this
Gordon's initial responses yeah but like
you literally use that as a talking
point against us to reveal to that point
the fact that the wealthy and the
powerful were profiteering off back port
whenever you know crime took place and
the value of parts of the city plummeted
like you've used this as a weapon
against us and now you want to use it
for yourself but Jack neighbors response
is but it's not selfishness I'm not
using it as like a slush fund to just
kind of pay you guys off the point of
the Batman deficit a devastation fund is
to remodel it and rework it into
something called a Gotham terror
oppression unit basically what this is
designed to do is to take the vigilante
element of batman batgirl and Nightwing
k-- bring them together and unify them
alongside the best cops on the surface
if we see like gotham terrorism
oppression unit my initial thought is
Jack Napier creating a secret police but
the way that he introduces this is it's
not like that it's basically taking the
vigilante element of Gotham and instead
of having it operate without any
accountability in no oversight like
Batman Batgirl and Nightwing do to pair
them up with cops to make sure there is
oversight and there's checks and
balances the good cops will keep the
vigil of vigilantes in check and the
unit as a whole will be able to reach
into parts of Gotham City's that cops
can't normally access and bring various
criminals to justice it's an exceedingly
great idea the argument that Jack Napier
makes here is look you say you need
Batman and that's fine but what you
actually need are Batman's resources if
the resources of Batman were available
to you as the Gotham police department
can you honestly say you would not be
better equipped to face off against the
the super criminals that exist inside
this city and so from here what we do is
we pick up with the whole idea of Lady
Joker or or Joker or I'm sorry neo Joker
and that's what you want to call it
remember in the last video what we ended
up finding out is that where Joker was
using the mind control device of the Mad
Hatter to control the various criminals
in Gotham City in order to basically set
up a ruse so that he could infiltrate
the offices of Mayor Hill and then learn
about the Batman devastation fund and so
on and so forth that a lady Joker had
essentially co-opted that technology
stolen it overridden it and took control
away from Jack Napier and so it means
she's now in control of the criminal
element of Gotham City in its entirety
and they're just running through and
they're ripping everything up in its
entirety now the whole idea behind this
is it again much like the Joker himself
it's a ruse it's designed for the
purpose of allowing her and in Mad
Hatter to get inside of the Gotham City
Police Department and then find some
some personal files and information this
being kept hidden by either Jack Napier
or the Gotham City PD itself discover
what those files are actually you know
access them and then go through and do
whatever it is they're gonna do with
them but the other cool thing to you is
that in the aftermath of this huge event
you have Batman and you have
Commissioner Gordon who sort of get into
an argument here and this is where Shaun
Murphy basically tells us Jack Napier's
won over Commissioner Gordon piece by
piece
Gotham's just being broken apart where
Commissioner Gordon is just like Jack
Napier is right if we had your
technology at our disposal Gotham City
could be a better place it could be
adequately protected and Jack Napier has
that plan I don't even know what your
name is
I'll even know who you are all I know is
that you're a guy who runs around Gotham
City in the middle of the night dressed
as a bat beating up people and I've
trusted you up to this point because
you've done what needed to be done
you've brought in the bad guys and so on
and so forth but what we have now is a
man who's shown up here with a concrete
solid verifiable and trustable plan on
how to make Gotham City better and
there's no reason not to trust it
essentially Commissioner Gordon kind of
makes this argument that I like Batman
you are becoming unnecessary now we now
have this guy Jack Napier who's willing
to work with us as opposed to alongside
us and then in turn make Gotham City a
better place we don't have to blindly
trust him and so at this point we
basically pick up with Jack Napier in in
Harley Quinn who were getting together
you know kind of kind of coming off of
you know touchin naughty bits and
ultimately they're met with the arrival
of neo Joker and this is of course when
we basically find out neo Joker was the
Harley Quinn at the beginning of the
story before the real Harley Quinn
showed up so she's basically fake Harley
but for the sake of this video we'll
just call her lady Joker going forward
just so there's no real confusion but
the coolest element of this of this
whole story really comes to play and we
actually learn about her origin we
basically figure this out when when we
end up having her meet or I guess
returned back to the Mad Hatter and the
reason why she ended up leaving Jack
Napier and and the original Harley Quinn
is because she basically says the only
way for me to actually win you back the
only way for me to get the Joker to come
back is for me to take over Gotham City
because the Joker's ego is too intense
to allow somebody else to win and so
because of this she goes through and
tells this huge origin story and she
essentially says that like she was a
person who cut herself she was
struggling with all kinds of anxiety
issues and depressive issues and so on
and she was in the process of actually
just kind of ending her own life and
then what do you know The Joker busts
into the bank and the Joker starts
robbing the joint but as soon as the
Joker put a gun to her head she wanted
to live and so in response to this the
Joker's started calling her Harley and
so she played
long this is kind of interesting here
under normal circumstances we would
expect a story almost identical to like
the original Harley Quinn instead she's
just kind of well depending on how you
look at it in the right place at the
right time or the wrong place at the
wrong time
but because Joker starts calling her
Harley she plays along under the hopes
that Joker will let her live that Joker
won't kill her but then because of the
fact that she looked so much like the
original Harley the Joker took her back
to his hideout gave her a Harley Quinn
outfit never touched her except for -
except for the bandage your wounds and
that's it but she basically became the
new Harley Quinn in the eye - the Joker
she was the new Harley now this is so
cool because what this does and what
this indicates here is the Joker's not
nearly as cold-hearted as we would
expect to expect to believe he is but
virtually every depiction of the Joker
going forward from like crisis on
Infinite Earths to the modern day has
always given us this version of the
Joker where he's effectively a person
who needs things he's like a child
crying out he needs the Batman because
the Batman makes him complete but what
this indicates is he needs Harley Quinn
The Joker's incomplete without Harley
Quinn if Harley Quinn was really that
irrelevant to the Joker if he really
cared that little about her then there
would be no reason for him to replace
her but the factor that Joker goes
through all these steps to make this
chick the new Harley Quinn indicates
that even if it's only on a subconscious
level he's created a new Harley and
that's why this works because this girl
Marion Druce she fell in love with him
The Joker completed her gave her a
reason to live because she's in such a
place where she needs to belong and
because the Joker's in such a place
where he needs a Harley Quinn that who
fall in love it's wild but picking back
up with with Jack Napier and him what we
end up having is Jack Napier and
Commissioner Gordon along with maybe a
couple of the cops who basically put on
the bat-signal Batman doesn't actually
show up instead which who shows up is
Nightwing and Barbara Gordon Batgirl and
this is when Commissioner Gordon and
Jack maybe you're sick we just want to
speak to You Tube we don't want to talk
to Batman and so what happens is Jack
Napier goes through and spills the beans
about the Gotham terrorists you know
terrorist outfit and says like this is
what we're shooting for three billion
dollars a year is what the Batman
devastation fund was pulling in we're
reworking it and in turn what we're
gonna do is we're gonna start outfitting
cars to start creating our own
Batmobiles and you guys are each gonna
get one we want you on board we want you
as a part of this now remember the whole
reason why Jack Napier does this is
because Barbara Gordon will listen to
her father
she'll go along with him Dick Grayson
will go along with her and Batman will
likely go along with the two of them
especially if he feels like he's
left out the cool thing about this is
remember Batman is very much a wild card
in these instances you can't guarantee
Batman will go along with them and so
ultimately what we end up doing is up
picking off with the data files that
lady Joker and Mad Hatter were sifting
through and what we start to do is find
out a handful of things one of which is
that a lot of the files that are going
on in the Gotham police department have
to do with Victor freeze that Victor
freeze was a Nazi that his father served
in the SS that what's going on here is
that despite all those things the
wealthiest and really the most powerful
family in Gotham City at the time the
Wayne's Thomas and Martha were meeting
with Victor freeze and what this
indicates is that Batman's own parents
had some pretty seedy dealings with some
pretty unsavory individuals that existed
inside of Gotham City okay so we are
picking up with part 5 of the white
knight and god this story just gets
better and better it is so intriguing
it's it's so interesting because it
starts out is like a stereotypical
Batman story then it turns them to light
the Joker going sane and then it's risen
like this story's gonna reveal like
there's so many secrets in Gotham and
like so many things about Batman that we
don't know but what this initially does
is it picks up with well really with
Jack Napier basically learning how to
become a better fighter now again one
thing my guys to bear in mind is when it
comes to him being sane this is my
routine popping of the pills it's not
permanent
right like I mean if he stops taking the
pills he'll go back to being the Joker
he's got the Joker at arm's reach but at
any point in time if somebody took the
pills and like hid them he'd go back to
being the Joker again so it's cool
because the whole idea of him being sane
just kind of runs on the edge of a knife
but him learning how to fight from
Harley Quinn it's cool because what this
is designed to do is to show that he's
basically captured everything and in
fact that's what's being said here in
the conversation between the two of them
Jack Napier's got at all he's got back
port basically he's got the the support
of all the people in Gotham or at least
most of them he's got the support of the
Gotham City Police Department he's got
the support of Nightwing he's got the
support of Batgirl the only person who
supported he does not have is Batman
and at the end of the day that doesn't
really seem to be a big part of the
picture anymore because when he looks at
where he is right now being a councilman
the idea that like he's easy some way
just like training to fight Batman in
hand-to-hand combat that's really like
the one thing he's shooting for is he's
taken everything that matters to Batman
so all this left is to basically take
Batman's dignity to beat him in a
hand-to-hand fight and call it a day and
so at this point we switch over to Bruce
Wayne to Batman who's been
sickly going through and investigating
everything that's been going on so far
with regards to like neo Joker and all
that kind of good stuff and the cool
thing about this is that initially as he
goes down like he immediately starts to
pick up the pieces and that's one thing
on what you guys have noticed about sean
Murphy's writing here
Batman's detective skills how
intelligent he is that's a bat that's an
afterthought it's a background thing
Sean Murphy doesn't spend a whole lot of
time dwelling on that because I mean
it's cool he doesn't treat us as the
reader as being stupid he's just kind of
like you guys know what's going on with
Batman you guys know he's smart you guys
know he'll figure stuff out so let's
worry about other things going on it's
very reminiscent of like Scott Snyder
Batman but when he's sitting down you
know of course he's met by Barbara
Gordon and Nightwing and of course he
deduces within a matter of minutes the
fact that all the villains who have been
operating in Gotham City have all been
mind-controlled basically that Clayface
has something to do with it because it's
the one villain that they haven't seen
yet but the big takeaway from this from
this encounter is that Nightwing and
Barbara Gordon try to convince Batman to
join the GTO and this is awesome because
Batman's response is no but notice his
reasoning here Batman doesn't simply say
no because you know like I don't trust
the GTF he says no because I don't trust
Jack Napier Batman is incapable of
letting go of the idea that Jack Napier
is the Joker and is a bad guy
Batman believes that like people can't
change that the Joker can't change and
mess was so ironic about this it's
Batman's entire mission is predicated on
rehabilitation it's predicated on the
idea that a villain can basically be
redeemed and become a good guy that's
why does it kill anybody but the instant
the Joker is redeemed
well then suddenly there's got to be
something going on it's basically one of
these things where like Batman has a
role to serve II as a purpose to serve
and II can't let it go Batman can't
function if there are no criminals in
Gotham and if Batman can't function
Bruce Wayne has no purpose and if Bruce
Wayne has no purpose then a purpose has
to be created and that's exactly what's
going on here to everyone who's looking
at Batman he's creating enemies because
he needs someone to fight someone out
there has to be wrong and that's why
this is so cool Dick Grayson is being
reasonable Barbara Gordon is being
reasonable
Jack Napier's plan is is really kind of
like the perfect compromise but Batman
and his stubbornness and his
unwillingness to admit defeat simply
sits down and says but there has to be a
caveat and that's where things get kind
of hairy because for us as the reader we
look at that and we say well he's
probably right because I mean his Batman
surely there has to be
catch but like at the at the same time
you look at this and you say but what if
there's not and it really kind of like
throws on a sharp relief the nature of
whether or not Batman is actually a hero
and so at this point we switch over to
an encounter with Batman and the real
Harley Quinn and the exchange is
interesting here because when it comes
to Harley Quinn as a character by and
large Batman has usually gone easy on
her but the reason for why Batman did
this is because in his mind Joker needed
some kind of counterbalance that if
Joker did not have something to anchor
him as close to reality as he could get
then like he would really fall off the
defend Batman says to Harley Quinn he
said we says we both know that as bad as
the Joker was we knew how bad he wanted
to be if you look at Harley Quinn in
this perspective this humanizes her it
changes her in her entirety the person
that was keeping the Joker anchored to
reality she's his anchor and without her
he just falls down into the path of
absolute insanity really beyond anything
that he was before and that also kind of
brings into question is that the reason
why the Joker found a second Harley
Quinn but regardless of the situation
ultimately you know when when Batman
hits her up and says look like you've
got to find a way to set things to
rights her response is no like I'm not
siding with you Jack Napier is a good
guy he's not the Joker anymore if you
can't get past that and then the problem
isn't Jack Napier the problem is you
everyone is taking sides against Batman
it's really him against the world
metaphorically and in some ways
physically Gotham City against Batman
and so from here we pick up with neo
Joker and Mad Hatter now these two
trying to break into into at Wayne Manor
this goes pretty par for the course in
this sense it like one you're talking
about like military-grade computer
systems but usually not like the the
highest levels of security and order
like access Wayne Manor to say nothing
of the computer and the Batcave and
where Mad Hatter goes through and tries
to hack in different things like that
what is up happening his neo Joker
actually uses her ability to control
criminals and Brees in poison ivy and
literally has her user vices start
snapping through and tearing down
different doors they're searching for
information that would connect the Wayne
family to the freeze family and the
freeze family was part of the German SS
back in World War two they're basically
trying to find a way to connect the dots
between Wayne and some pretty seedy
things that happened during the Second
World War and so as a result of this
poison ivy the various plants she uses
some of them are able to basically sense
like stale air indicating there's a room
with a door that hasn't been open in
forever and so they actually find the
room managed to tap in there but then
Bruce Wayne realizes what's going on
when like you know the alarms go off and
this is hilarious this is what this one
the funniest parts of the story because
when they get in there and they start
sniffing around may find blueprints for
like underground tunnels different
things like that suddenly Bruce Wayne
comes flying out of nowhere
I hear you hooligans he's just like this
rich guy terrified for his life and
truth he could have just sort of lost it
and like gone after the two of them and
just started ripping things up
I remember when you're Batman you you
kind of recognize it sometimes the best
fight is the one that lasts the long
term it's the one where you gather all
the information that you need and having
like neo Joker in Mad Hatter bust into
his house and then start searching
through a room where he could show up
his Batman is well let's follow them
let's see what's going on let's see what
they're doing and let's even check out
this room because one of the things we
find out is that of course you have
Nightwing who responds as part of the
gto and Batman suddenly says like they
were in a room that I didn't even know
existed he had no idea that it was there
and so at this point it's really more
questions racing through his mind than
answers but the cool thing is that we're
night wasted Lee says hey man looked
like mr. Wayne chill man the GTO has got
this what we end up having is him of
course you know basically donning his
Batman outfit now this is beautiful the
way that Shaun Murphy does this is
absolutely stunning because what we have
here is the GTO chasing after neo Joker
basically going after neo Joker and
going after Mad Hatter and they should
be able to take them out and in fact
they're catching up with them they're
able to hold their own some of the
criminals of neo Joker are being called
in to kind of you know back off and
force off some of the gto but then you
end up having like the forces of
backport that show up and so they start
taking out criminals too so for the most
part neo Joker and Mad Hatter are
effectively finished trying to mean it's
only a matter of time they're gonna
chase them to a bridge or something like
that but it's only a matter of time
before they get caught and then here
comes Batman and what he actually ends
up doing is ruining everything he screws
it all up and that's what's so great
about this is because we look at Batman
as the guy who shows up and saves the
day Batman's the superhero Batman saves
the day that's what Batman does instead
like you have a city that's basically
able to stand on its own two feet now
that doesn't need Batman anymore but he
makes his presence known Batman has to
exist he has to be there even if it
means screwing things up making things
worse and so of course where he grabs a
couple of the documents here he gets
ahold of neo Joker but she makes her
escape
alongside Mad Hatter and he grabs a
couple of pages they basically show
Thomas Wayne next to one of the freezes
from world war ii the bridge ultimately
Colossus and then you immediately have
Gordon who says enough is enough
everybody's just fed up with Batman
they're tired of it how many resources
have been wasted because of Batman
here's a foolproof plan called the GTO
to basically have vigilantes and and the
Gotham City Police Department work
together and then here comes Batman Anna
left field
you know ruining everything tearing
everything up mate you know kind of
reiterating the point of Jack Napier
Batman is not a superhero or a benefit
for Gotham City Batman's a liability
he's a hassle Batman is a pain in the
backside and Jim Gordon finally sees the
light and says Batman is no longer a
vigilante in the city of Gotham Batman
is a super criminal APB I want an APB
out all-points bulletin
Batman is to be arrested on sight and so
from here we switch over to Bruce Wayne
showing up at the home of Victor freeze
showing up with these documents smashing
that that image down on the paper you
know down on down the local paper and
says start talking and mr. Freeze's
response is the Wayne family has many
secrets they have a lot of Secrets but
the most amazing part of this drop-off
here is that Victor freeze reveals to
Batman that he knows that he's Bruce
Wayne how long he's known we don't know
but we know that he like he knows that
he's Bruce Wayne that's what's so crazy
about this okay so we are jumping back
into Batman the white knight and here's
the deal I kind of okay so with the
camera I like having the camera and
doing FaceTime when I'm like explaining
ideas but with stories I don't really
see a reason to change that I don't
really see a reason to change the format
that we currently have at the moment I
think it's kind of cool because it
allows the emphasis to be on what we're
talking about so much as me just like
explaining things so with better than
the white knight this is this is cool
because what the story does this is one
reason why Shaun Murphy's riding is so
interesting as it seems to follow like
the traditional standard of storytelling
to a point in the sense that we
basically have like a set of
circumstances we're familiar with right
like the first third of the story
basically opened up a really yeah I
guess the first third so far opened up
with like here's how Gotham City works
that's basically Batman as you're used
to him the Joker is a bad guy Batman's
tasting him around so on so forth pretty
straightforward and then suddenly it's
the shift and it's well Joker then
become sane and he becomes a good guy
so the whole idea here had basically
been how does Joker as a good guy as
Jack Napier present the scenario that
Batman is actually more of a hindrance
for Gotham City than a benefit and
that's when he started rolling in things
like the Batman devastation fund the
idea that when Batman went into a
neighborhood and thing
when arrived but the property values of
the neighborhood would absolutely
plummet the wealthy would go in and buy
up all the property they would wait for
the for the gotham city government to
use the devastation fund or the
emergency fund to basically fix
everything and then when the property
values went back up the wealthy would
sell them because of that like with all
these other things going on the overall
gist of this is that Jack Napier has put
out the narrative that while Batman
doesn't know him he's basically an
enforcer for the wealthy against the
poor and it's so cool because Bruce said
had no idea what was going on and the
picture that have been painted by Jack
Napier was like it doesn't matter if he
doesn't know that's the way it is what
what what you think is going on is
irrelevant in the face of what's
actually going on and so the whole the
whole basis behind us was for Jack
Napier to basically say the only way for
Gotham City to actually become the city
that it wants to be to become this
beacon of what Batman is shooting for
this beacon of hope and light much like
metropolis is for Gotham City to do it
on its own is regardless city to cast
off Batman because for everyone out
there who looks at Gotham City as a
potential place to live what they'll
always say is well what happens when
that man stops being Batman what happens
when he dies or he retires whatever the
case may be what happens when Batman
ceases to exist then what happens to
Gotham and I'm not moving my family to a
town that's gonna go to pieces as soon
as Batman's killed or something along
those lines no one sees it as like a
viable opportunity for like the
long-term and so that's the basis of
Jack Napier is to say like we can revamp
the city and make it our own the issue
with this is that Batman is still on the
fringe and Batman is still operating
under the idea that while Jack Napier is
popping pills and he's basically same
now keeping the Joker persona completely
curved it in the background the time
will come when he will become the Joker
again and Batman's eyes it's only a
matter of time where Batman had kind of
jumped in and basically stopped the
Gotham City Police Department and you
know Nightwing and Batgirl from
capturing neo Joker and the Mad Hatter
while it wasn't his intention to like
allow those villains to go his actions
resulted in them going away and so what
this has done is as put Batman in a
position to where Nightwing and Barbara
Gordon are somewhat siding against him
now Barbara Gordon is still kind of
walking the middle ground here Nightwing
is on Batman's side in so far that when
the arguments made like Batman needs to
be rounded up and mid will unmask him so
everybody knows who he really is don't
know that we caught him legitimately
Nightwing Stan's is no no you know we
bring Batman
in but at the end of the day he keeps
his mask and it's kind of cool because
it's still really night Ouisa attachment
to like the legacy of batman keeping
that aspect of himself private and so
initially with barbara gordon again
she's on the fence here right like like
barbara gordon stance is like look we Oh
Bruce Wayne now in truth in this story
where we're basically given the notion
that like The Killing Joke happened
Robert Gordon was shot she was paralyzed
she was Oracle and now she's where she
is now we are given those little tidbits
here and there but for Barbara Gordon it
seems to go much deeper than the fact
that like she was shot by the Joker once
and you know eventually came back to
health and you know she was Batgirl all
that kind of cool stuff it's it's
loyalty is what this is loyalty to the
ideology of what Batman stands for and
what Gotham City needs if the ideology
of what Batman stands for that makes all
this so significant and so with that in
mind like ultimately she just kind of
walks out and says look if you guys are
gonna do this I cannot be a party to
this whole situation and so ultimately
what you end up having is you have Jack
Napier and you have everybody else kind
of rounding up and then suddenly coming
up with ideas or trying to figure out
ideas on how to take out Batman because
the guy is quite literally a one-man
army
the various tools he has at his disposal
the various forms of travel their
military great a person with a sniper
rifle on a building is not gonna be able
to kill Batman by shooting him through
the glass in the in the front window of
the Batmobile it wasn't designed for
that purpose the one thing that it can't
deflect is an EMP because it has
electronic components it needs those
things the reason why nobody ever
thought about using an EMP before is
because of collateral damage it would
not only take out the Batmobile they
would take out like whatever vehicles
were chasing after him and they would
take out power within like you know a
six block radius and with Batman having
his resources at his disposal even if
they took down the Batmobile Batman
would be able to make his escape and
then they'd be no better off than they
were before and the city of Gotham would
hate them because they'd taken down
power to a portion of the city and so
they come up with this really really
genius idea
Nightwing basically steals this old
analog style Batmobile that didn't
really run on the same level of
electronics that the current version
does if every were correctly this is a
throwback to Batman the Animated Series
which I kind of like about this it's
pretty cool and it's pretty interesting
to see but what they end up doing is
they basically like chase them into a
warehouse and then suddenly it it's like
blank on all these lights which of
course blinds Batman
and then they detonate this EMP and the
idea is that because the warehouse is
lined with lead the EMP will only affect
Batman's Batmobile it won't affect
anything else around the city and with
the older version of the Batmobile that
Gordon's driving running you know
basically an analogue vehicle without
all the other digital components that
currently exists in the newest version
his vehicle will run along just as well
as anybody else's and that's what
happens when is up going on here his
Batman is of course you know blinded and
taken by surprise with the whole thing
Jim Gordon fishtails Batman swerves
under him and sends him flying into a
pole and where Batman initially makes
his escape from from Jim Gordon he's met
by the arrival of Jack Napier and this
is awesome this is part of one of the
coolest moments in the whole story
because this is like the fight scene
from like they live right like Rowdy
Roddy Piper versus that one black dude
who does the narrations for the Navy
it's just a bare-knuckle fight between
Jack Napier and Batman and under normal
circumstances we would expect Jack
Napier to basically have his backside
handed to him quite readily by the Dark
Knight but remember Jack Napier has been
training here now this is where I kind
of think that that Shawn Murphy fudges
the numbers a bit Batman is the
culmination of like decades of martial
arts training Jack Napier doesn't have
anywhere near that level of training now
an argument could be made that like Jack
Napier was able to capitalize on Batman
being injured that's really the only
reason why Batman was in a weakened
state so on and so forth but we have to
believe that with all the battles of
Batman's fought over the course of his
existence as a superhero of all the
life-threatening injuries he sustained
all the times that he pushed himself to
the limit and kept on going that he
would be able to overcome this but
that's the beauty of this story being a
miniseries that's not in continuity
basically it's Shawn Murphy telling us
everything else you know throw it away
like throw it out and the fight between
the two of them is hardcore this fight
is is the culmination of just like years
and decades of Batman chasing after the
Joker so these guys are fighting with
their heart and soul every ounce of
anger every ounce of vitriol every ounce
of hate being poured into this this
physical battle the issue with this is
that Batman's injuries get the better of
him and Jack Napier comes out on top and
so what we end up doing is having Jack
Napier basically take the body of Bruce
Wayne directly back to Commissioner
Gordon everybody and they end up
throwing him into Arkham Asylum and
essentially intending to leave him in
the issue with this is that before any
of this can basically happen we end up
having like this giant gun that was used
by neo Joker this giant freeze gun
that's fired on the city of Gotham and
what she does is right into the side of
several buildings send the Joker now
this is where things get really really
interesting this is actually where I
think Shawn Murphy goes a totally
different direction but it all sort of
ties everything in together Victor fries
for the most part in the story was just
a guy who's there and in the early issue
the question that had to be asked was
why is he here what this does is it
basically says like that his father was
departed the Axis powers that Thomas
Wayne was part of the Allied powers and
the two of them basically crossed paths
when Thomas Wayne learned of the
cryogenics research that was being
performed by the father of Victor freeze
and where the US military industrial
complex wanted to use the father of
Victor freezes research for weapons use
Thomas Wayne wanted to use it for a
source of healing and Victor freeze
agreed with this idea using those things
to make the world a better place
and so because of this Victor freeze is
just kind of a guy who operated in the
background and seems to have like a
long-standing relationship with the
Wayne's insofar that he goes all the way
back to Thomas and where he spilled all
this information to Bruce he's spilling
all the information of Robert Gordon
right now the other half of this is that
the way that Victor fries found out the
identity of Bruce Wayne was that when
Bruce Wayne was initially injured at the
beginning of the story and then showed
up back and then Alfred basically you
know Bruce Wayne woke up and Alfred was
in a chair dead and Bruce Wayne was
hooked up to the freeze technology which
he kept him alive what we know finding
out as Victor freeze was there that
Alfred is simply calling us up like you
have to come here you have to help out
you have to get Bruce Wayne back on his
feet offered sacrifices life for that
purpose but the promise that Victor made
at the behest of a dying man was you
cannot tell anybody the identity of
Bruce Wayne I'm not making this request
because I can I somehow have the ability
to enforce it I'm making this request
because you're an honorable man and I
know that you will honor it Victor fries
goes through who talked about his father
you know Baron von freeze he despised
what is what his father stood for he
despised what his father was about and
that's why all this is being done now
the biggest downside of this and the
reason why this is so cool is because
Barbara Gordon showed up here looking
for answers finding a way to like
deactivate this freeze gun Victor
freezes responses my father built it I
don't know anything about it I can't
deactivate this thing for you I can't
undo this you're gonna have to find a
different way and so ultimately she just
ends up leaving no better off than she
was when she first got here and so what
we do is we pick back up with Jack
Napier and again this is where the whole
argument kind of comes to fruition of
the sense that like Jack Napier's lost
control of everything Jack Napier took
the quick and easy path he just kind of
walked into the situation that in his
hubris and in his arrogance of believing
he could conquer the city of Gotham what
he didn't take into account is all the
wild cards characters like like neo
Joker and collateral damage and it's
like that's the one thing Batman always
realized that's sure you can move this
chess piece here but if you do somebody
else is gonna move there
peace there it's not a game that's
played where there's no consequence and
this is kind of Shaun Murphy throwing
into our face is this idea that Batman
walks a knife's edge at every single
time Bruce Wayne Dawn's the cape and
cowl and every single time he goes out
into the city of Gotham his Batman he
has to weigh the pros and cons of every
decision he makes and while Bruce
Wayne's intelligence allows him to do
that
Jack Napier is a guy who's popping pills
to keep the Joker persona at bay he is
not Bruce Wayne and so this is cool
because essentially the argument by
Hawaii by Harley Quinn is you've totally
lost control the situation like you
spend so much time trying to develop the
Gotham anti-terrorist group you've spent
so much time trying to sit down and try
to be Bruce Wayne you never took the
time to realize that you cannot be Bruce
Wayne because you are not Bruce Wayne
and you cannot function in the same
capacity as Batman what is it happening
is you basically have Jack Napier who
essentially gives in he goes and he
meets with everybody with with with the
Gotham City police with the vigilantes
with with everyone here and the
questions asked what do we do she's
demanding the Joker what option do we
have
and Jack Nabors responses there's only
one option that we have and he
essentially allows his Joker persona to
cut loose and we end up seeing the
return of the Joker okay so we are
jumping back into Batman the white
knight we're on issue number seven we're
almost done we have like this one and
then one like the conclusion and and God
do this story so god this story is is
it's crazy how good this whole thing is
all right so basically what we have here
like like we pick up with this whole
thing with like the Joker quote-unquote
returning and that's kind of the cool
thing here is in all honesty I love the
idea of Jack Napier I love the idea of
like the Joker going sane but at the end
of the day it is the Joker I like the
Joker as the crazy guy everybody likes
the Joker as the crazy guy and that's
really what Shaun Murphy gives us to a
degree and it's cool the way he puts a
sort of twist on the way he puts this
kind of caveat on it is what we end up
finding out is that with the Joker
personality kicking back in what's
happening is the meds are losing their
effect basically his body's becoming
immune to it and the result is that the
Joker personality is constantly pushing
itself out and it's cool because it
gives us this kind of internal battle
between like Jack Napier and the Joker
himself which is something that I'd love
to see with regards to like how this
story's unfolding but for here we switch
over to Batman and again this is kind of
cool because Batman is of course locked
up in Arkham Asylum and the one thing
that I've been seeing in the commets
this is why I love the way Shaun Murphy
writes this the one thing I've been
seeing in the comments really more than
anything else is no way Batman would be
locked up in Arkham Asylum
he knows a million ways to get out this
is one of the things that I want you
guys to notice about Batman and
hopefully it's one of the things that
you guys have picked up on as we've gone
through this story Batman as he's
depicted here in this particular story
is kind of primitive I mean it's not
like he's like stupid or anything like
that but like when you compare the way
like this Batman dresses or like the
quality of the Batcave or the vehicle he
drives to like the DC rebirth Batman
they almost seem like night and day this
guy's wearing what amounts to like
weightlifting gloves and he's got like a
Batman uniform on but it doesn't quite
have the same kind of pizzazz right like
the same kind of shiny polished you know
I'm Batman and I'm so technologically
advanced and I'm like a man from the
future you don't see those kind of
things in this this is a far more
grounded far more tangible and far more
real Batman and it works it works so
well because this is the kind of Batman
you would expect to see what makes
Batman unique and the reason why he kind
of stands the test of time regardless of
like what his uniform is is the
intelligence and the martial arts skill
of Batman his ability to like deduce
things that people wouldn't normally be
able to pick up combined with his
ability to just beat the crap out of
people that's what makes Batman timeless
you know sort of Shaun Murphy putting
his own twist on how Batman looks while
simultaneously giving us the character
that we all know and love and so from
here it picks up with Jack Napier going
to meet neo Joker because remember she's
basically kind of like taken over the
city of Gotham right I mean usually like
this massive freeze cannon that was
developed by the father of Victor freeze
what she's done is basically just like
frozen over the city of Gotham but with
regards to neo Joker she's like the new
Harley Quinn that was the whole basis of
the story the original Harley Quinn left
without Jack Napier Joker ever realizing
it the new Harley Quinn took his place
and then when the old one came back the
new Harley took off and became neo Joker
she became the new version of the Joker
but her idea has always been I want
Joker back it's cool because in a lot of
ways neo Joker kind of represents the
fan base ice is the reader we sit down
we start reading Batman the white knight
because we see the solicitations all
over the place in DC rebirth and we're
like wow that looks cool and then we
start cracking it open we started just
tearing through the pages and we're like
oh my god this is one of the greatest
Batman stories ever written but then
like we start to see Joker go sing and
at the end of the day it's like that's
cool but like I want to see the Joker
I want the Joker back and so neo Joker
is kind of a stand-in for us that like
we want to see the Joker return in some
form or fashion
Jack Napier's idea is fine if you want
the Joker back then we'll bring in the
Joker back and he lets that part of his
personality kind of break
for a moment when he suddenly says like
the Joker will return on my terms and so
that's kind of a cool thing notice this
Jack Napier begins to kind of use the
Joker as a weapon it's his own gun his
his switchblade his pocket knife it's a
weapon for him to use to achieve a
certain goal now the other thing to bear
in mind here is he doesn't have total
control in this instance he sort of just
you know opens the door unless the Joker
come out and then shuts the door again
it's like dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde it's
like Bruce Banner in the Incredible Hulk
just because the Joker's there and Jack
Napier let him out does it mean that
Jack Napier has control over the Joker
and that's why this is awesome is
because we kind of get the best of both
worlds for this short short span of time
the other thing to bear in mind here is
the original Harley Quinn Harley's torn
up about this like Jack maybe you're
going saying Jack maybe you're becoming
a regular guy was the greatest thing
that could happen to him because in the
mind of Harley Quinn he can finally do
what Batman has never been able to do
every day Batman is one step forward one
step back he's a dog chasing his tail
he's going nowhere but with Jack Napier
it was legitimately changing Gotham City
effecting change in a way that could
tangibly be seen and tangibly be felt
that's what made him so successful is he
won the hearts and minds of people but
that's the interesting thing here is
because when you look at this situation
you say yeah sure he cleaned up Gotham
because none of the villains are there
but none of the villains are there
because they're all under the control of
neo Joker and that's the question that
Shawn Murphy asked did he really save
Gotham City or does it just look that
way because the circumstances are
unfolding themselves in a way that keeps
the villains at bay while everything
seems to be going back to normal
not only that Batman had basically
figured out that because Harley Quinn
was the one who was working so hard to
try to keep Jack Napier Jack Napier sane
at the end of the day Batman has figured
out that like Harley Quinn will push
Jack Napier in the direction of seeking
out the help of Batman because there's
no other option that he has it's the
only choice he has here the Joker needs
Batman and in a lot of ways a neo Joker
was right when she said the Joker is
going to come back and make his return
because his ego won't let neo Joker
conquer Gotham but Gotham is is a
half-measure it's incomplete if Batman's
not there and so with Jack Napier
showing up and suddenly saying like if I
let the Joker out if I let him run amok
sure he'll take out neo Joker and he'll
conquer Gotham as well because you're
not out there you're not out there
stopping here me not out there chasing
him and so Jack Napier grabs Batman
brings him along and says you've got to
save me here but this is kind of a cool
moment because the two of them sort of
get into this argument like Jack maybe
you're in Batman sort of argue with one
another over who it is is actually doing
any good Jack De Beers argument is
made Gotham a better place in ways that
you've never been able to do and your
entire career as Batman and while I
can't necessarily stop all those
villains what I've done is I've managed
to get the people to care about the city
that they live in they don't live in
fear anymore they live in in confidence
that they can walk down the street and
keep their city safe from everybody else
they're not relying on you and you've
never been able to effect that change
you've never been able to inspire people
but Batman's argument is yeah but you
broke the law to do it and the jack
neighbor comes back with this perfect
argument and says yeah but so did you
you're a vigilante you operated outside
of the law you weren't held accountable
to anybody I got to the support of the
public I work with the police I don't
work alongside them as someone who's
just there it's an awesome argument
because that's 100% true I think in
years to come people will look at this
and see it as like a critique of Batman
that's what it is it's a critique of the
Batman character he operates outside of
the law he does what he wants when he
wants how he wants and it just happens
to be that he works in the interests of
Gotham City Batman says like my
allegiance is to Gotham but at no point
has he sought the help of the people and
no point has he has he inspired the
people to do something better
he's always simply just taken the weight
of the city on his shoulders and said
it's my job now to protect everyone
whereas Jack Napier took the people to
the fight said look I am here like you
I'm not someone above the city itself I
am a citizen I do all the things that
I'm supposed to I want to be a part of
this role of this army of Gotham I don't
want to lead this army of Gotham and
that's why it's so awesome and that's
why it works so up now ultimately
because of the fact that like the
overarching goal is to take out neo
Joker the two of them end up hearing up
the jack navier's argument is look when
that man says I want a full confession
from you for everything that you've done
since you've been Jack Napier all the
criminal activity that you've been
involved in because he has been involved
in some pretty seedy stuff he has broken
the law he says I want a full confession
Jack Napier says fine I'll give you your
confession but Harley Quinn has to go
free you cannot have Harley Quinn
intertwine in this she does not get
arrested for anything and this is cool
because this is like the one unifying
factor that Joker and Jack Napier ship
Harley Quinn Harley Quinn well while we
may say that like Batman is the center
of Joker's world to a degree that's true
but the fact that like Harley the
original holiday Quinn took off and like
Joker sought out a new one means Joker
always needs a Harley Quinn she's an
intrinsic part of his life with Jack
Napier it's the same way he always has
her by his side she's as close as
confidant and so of course with the two
of them teaming up
what we end up having is Batman asking
the question saying if we work together
there's one thing that I want to know I
want to know what happened to Jason Todd
because remember Shaun Murphy kind of
flipped the script on us with this one
well we ended up finding out here is
Jason Todd was Robin before Dick Grayson
and main DC continuity Dick Grayson was
Robin long before Jason Todd Jason Todd
was the second Robin Hendrick was a
third and then Damian Wayne was the
fourth and so all we really knew was
that the whole situation involving Jason
Todd went down almost identical to like
death in the family and that was awesome
because that story is so landmark in the
Batman mythos but it was basically the
idea that like Joker had killed Jason
Todd what we end up having is this
revelation coming from from Jack Napier
that like Jason Todd's not dead
we end up finding out that like the one
thing that Joker wanted was to know the
identity of Batman not so he could take
him out by knowing the identity of
Batman Joker would know something that
Batman didn't and so Joker would have
something on him he'd have a measure of
control over Batman if all else fails
it'd be the one thing Joker knows that
Batman doesn't isn't aware of the Joker
knows and so when Jason Todd just kind
of snapped you know when when when he
basically offered his last words and
said I wish I never met Bruce Wayne
Joker cuts him loose because he's
finally revealed the identity but that's
where jack neighbor kind of makes his
revelation Jason Todd's alive he's not
dead he's free floating out there in the
world somewhere who knows maybe he'll
come back as Red Hood we have no earthly
clue but he wants you to believe he's
dead because he felt like you betrayed
him that you took him under under your
wing to become Robin we don't really
know that backstory we can largely
surmise that it happened the same way it
did in the post-crisis landscape
basically Jason Todd was a guy who
boosted you know almost who stole the
wheels off the Batmobile basically but
like we can assume that happened but we
don't know for sure all we know is that
Jason Todd became Robin somewhere along
the line and the result was that were
the two of them largely fought as a
dynamic duo that when when Jason Todd
was brought into the world of Batman he
was brought into a world of danger and
death and so when Jay 20n Todd was taken
by the Joker was having the absolute
Harvie out of him and on the edge of
dying
the one thing he resented above all
others was being brought in by Bruce
Wayne was being adopted by Bruce Wayne
he wishes he'd never met the man and so
that seems to instill this massive
hatred for Batman on behalf of Jason
Todd and it's cool because it works
because what this does is it sets things
up for like the introduction of the Red
Hood its Shawn Murphy you know if this
story really became as huge as is as it
seems to be if it really is one of these
things were like it turns into a story
that Shawn Murphy can build off of then
we can
Red Hood introduced the foundation is
already there but again with the two of
them kind of siding and kind of working
together Batman has to put out a little
bit of pass behind him he has to kind of
walk away from that whole situation and
focus almost strictly on the here and
now and so going to visit Victor freeze
and asking the question of how it is
that Victor freeze is going to help with
this whole situation Victor says the
same thing that he told Barbara Gordon
there's nothing I can do here I don't
know how this machine works construction
on this massive weapon started after I'd
already left my father when I took off
and I came to the United States I don't
know the ins and outs of it but what he
does do is he offers us information on
how to like access the island of where
the machines at without you know neo
Joker knowing what he basically says is
like when the machine was being
constructed because Batman asked how
could it how could this thing have been
built with no one knowing about it and
Victor fre says they were using tunnels
you know literally Thomas Wayne had
tunnels constructed under Gotham City
that basically all reached to this one
specific location they brought in all
kinds of things to see this thing
constructed underground so nobody would
be aware of it and that's what's awesome
is because it's one of these things like
you mr. Gordon kind of says it himself
you never learn everything about Gotham
City there's always something new to
learn but again this is Shawn Murphy
kind of turning the table flipping the
script and a lot of things and saying
Thomas Wayne I'm worth way more like the
kindly people who were just in the wrong
place at the wrong time it would just
shot in cold blood by Joe Chill they
have a dark history and so ultimately
they end up basically outlining
themselves you know what kind of coming
together The Joker banding alongside
Batman who's working alongside the bat
family who's working alongside the
Gotham police department this entire
group basically led by Batman and the
Joker they end up like making their way
towards the island where neo Joker is
currently residing and the idea is
Batman Sibley says like okay this is
your shot jack like this is your shot to
get out there get into the head of neo
Joker and basically serve as a
distraction
we have no idea what'll happen to him
but like your job is to get in there to
be a distraction and get into her head
while we get in there and basically take
everything down to bring this entire
empire crumbling down around her after
which we have no clue what happens we
have to wait for the next issue
okay so I am running on like three hours
of sleep right now so you guys are gonna
have to bear with me
I am totally exhausted but this is the
conclusion of Batman the white knight
and whole week how do Shawn Murphy's
pulling out all the stops and I love
this here's the cool thing about DC
rebirth and these these Batman esque or
these miniseries that are going on these
are miniseries that like they could
build off of you can make universes out
of each one of these miniseries and
that's what's so cool about this is it
gives us this really cool story and then
it makes us want more right I mean up to
this point it was basically that like
Jack Napier somehow got his hands on a
set of pills that he could take and the
Joker personality would recede and it
would allow the Jack Napier personality
to arise and it was the first time that
we'd seen that so you basically had like
this sane rational human being that
initially seemed to be turning the city
of Gotham on Batman which was true to a
degree but then it was more along the
lines of let's fix the city of Gotham
because Batman's not doing it now
ultimately things one arrived the
original Harley Quinn who basically left
she was replaced by the new Harley Quinn
and then when Jack Napier went sane he
went back to the original Harley Quinn
and the new Harley Quinn started calling
herself neo Joker and then activated
this giant freeze cannon that basically
froze Gotham City and that's where we're
at at the moment and when you get into
this whole thing is basically Joker and
Batman have to team up to take on neo
Joker because that was the ultimatum the
ultimatum was if you want me to fix
things
send me the Joker give me Joker back and
this it's kind of holding the city of
Gotham and ransom and it puts Batman in
a very precarious situation because on
one hand who knows what neo Joker will
do to the actual Joker maybe she's so
obsessed with him she'll kill him you
know
the whole play misty for me kind of
situation or it could be that like
she'll do the two of them will run off
and they'll start committing more crimes
in Gotham and things will be worse than
they were before
you know Neo Joker rose to prominence
before all this Hobbit it creates like a
very very tough situation and so
ultimately this is kind of like the
Gotham basically the Gotham anti-terror
group the police working alongside the
rest of the bat family essentially
working to track down neo Joker now I
remember in the the last couple story
arcs the last couple issues what Shaun
Murphy established is that neo Joker had
seized control of the entire Gotham
villain community and so they're under
her control and they're doing exactly we
would expect they're really more like
standing in the way than anything else
they're again kind of serving their
purpose really play more security than
anything else
but what it does is it basically allows
man and Joker to essentially penetrate
penetrate through the defenses the
forces of poison ivy and men like show
up or neo Joker is and that's what ended
up having like actual Joker show up to
neo Joker and that's the cool thing
that's what I love so much about this
it's almost kind of like this in comic
book idea that there's two versions of
the Joker there's the Joker we think we
know and then there's the actual Joker
and that's really were where neo Joker
is at the moment right I mean you have
this chick and she's like oh I love the
Joker I love the idea of what he does
he's so fun and you know and how we love
hanging out with him because he made me
feel like I was alive you know and then
there is the Joker as he really is and
it's almost like this idea that like
he's been pulling punches all this time
because when he shows up he immediately
attacks neo Joker her idea was it like
the Joker would return and the two of
them would be in love and they would run
off hand in ham the Joker would love her
and all those things that's not true at
all the Joker wants to take her out now
of course following this you end up
basically having the technology of the
Mad Hatter which is destroyed by the
Joker himself and that means I like the
control over all the villains by neo
Joker is essentially released but what
this does is it leads Clayface into
essentially attacking the Joker now this
is kind of a cool thing we only get this
for a couple panels right like we only
get this for a maybe you know three
panels four panels or what have you it's
not the biggest thing in the world
but it is cool it really is indicative
of like the danger that Clayface poses
they don't stay and say oh man we got to
defeat Clayface no but they run because
in this situation Clayface would destroy
them now the other half of this is that
with Harley you know that the original
Harley and Jack Napier jumping into the
jumping into the Batmobile Jack maybe
has been able to seize control the Joker
persona has been pushed back and is kind
of like this this dedication to Harley
Quinn what it really does here is he
basically sits down and says you were
the only one in Gotham City that ever
really believed that I existed nobody
believed that there was a good side to
the Joker and so it's a way for Jack
Napier to basically say look like I
fallen in love with you all over again
and it's this amazing experience because
from there like you end up having like
neo Joker who shows up you know kind of
racing alongside them because Clayface
damaged the Batmobile and neo Joker says
there's room for one more on this thing
and
Jack Napier is coming with me and the
funny thing is that Jackson initial
response is no Harley Quinn needs to
live and so what is up happening is
Jackie basically says look only one of
us is gonna make this out of this we're
crashing we were we're coming up on a
wall only one of us is gonna make it out
he hits the button he ejects Harley
Quinn and Jack Napier smashes into the
wall and the Batmobile explodes and I
saw this and I was just like
holy cow no way it was I was just like
wow because like you you never really
see that like you read the whole thing
about about you know Batman the white
knight and it's like well of course
Jackie Napier's gonna make it to the end
and of course Jack Napier is gonna so
act no way he's gonna die here and then
you look at this whole thing and it's
like Jesus I mean the explosion
basically starts wreaking havoc within
the that cave itself you end up having
leaks all these different things that go
on now of course because Victor freeze
had come along with the bat family in an
effort to basically reverse engineer
this giant freeze cannon that his father
made of course it does work I couldn't
really see the story ending with Gotham
City you know Gotham City just being
frozen over forever but then what we
also end up figuring out finding out
here it's a Jack Napier basically
survived that that man brings it like he
jumps into the water brings him back to
the surface and Jack Napier makes it
enough from there it switches over to
the fight between Harley Quinn and neo
Joker and this is not a fight that's
based out of any real perspective of
like the direction Gotham City should go
in it's a core between two women who
believe they've lost a man they love and
his and it's interesting because it's a
fight over love but the cool thing about
this is remember Neo Joker is the new
kid on the block she didn't have all
that experience she hasn't been around
all this time but when you're talking
about classic Harley Quinn she's not
someone to snuff that she can be really
really dangerous and so her lashing out
initially she goes to kill like neo
Joker but then suddenly you know you
basically have Duke Thomas who jumps on
her and you're in her earpiece and says
Jack Napier's alive you're fine like do
not kill that chick because if that
happened then classic Harley Quinn would
cross the line she can't come back from
something else at all I want you guys to
also notice too is that the various
villains are being carted away in a
Gotham City police vehicle this is the
same kind of vehicle you saw from Batman
the Animated Series question for you
guys if it has nothing to do with this
story which show do you think was better
Batman the Animated Series were extra in
the animated series I'm biased I'm
saying x-men but I'm curious to see
which one you guys come up with but
nonetheless you know with this whole
thing the agreement was that if Jack
Napier I guess you know was if he was
essentially kind of allowed to go free
or at least you know working alongside
Batman then he would have a full
confession he would confess to
everything that he did when he was Jack
Napier when he was working behind the
scenes when he was manipulating things
that was the whole point he had to make
a confession which he does but this is
kind of a beautiful moment because
they're essentially like uh shirt off
you know like Jack Napier's assured off
to his prison cell which is really more
of like a nicer version the one that I
think previously belong to Harley Quinn
when she used to study him as the Jo
and what happens is he basically tells
like like Batman and Commissioner Gordon
you have to marry us like if like I've
want to marry Harley Quinn but I want to
marry her as Jack Napier I don't want to
have to marry her as the Joker and the
issue is that the Joker keeps trying to
push himself back out he keeps trying to
make his appearance no and so you end up
having a priest that kind of shows up
and he just runs through all the wedding
a true wedding announcement you know
like hey Jack Napier do you take all he
couldn't marry you and he's like I do
it's like Harley Quinn do you promise to
do all the stuff that I just said to
Jack Napier and she's like I do and then
before Jack niebuhr can say like I do
The Joker personality pops up and he's
like I do this is it's not a great big
huge moment this feeds into the part of
the story where Shaun Murphy built up
the idea that Joker was legitimately in
love with Harley Quinn and that with the
Joker persona and the jack neighbour
persona fighting over the same body The
Joker went out because his love for
Harley Quinn was just that much more
extreme but it is kind of interesting
and it is kind of funny here and so what
we end up doing is picking up in the
aftermath of this whole white knight
event and the sense that you basically
have Jack navier's confession
essentially saying hey look when I
became sane I realized that Gotham City
would never trust me so I basically set
up circumstances I used criminals I set
them loose so everybody would look there
and then I infiltrated the mayor's
office and then in turn stole
information about the Batman devastation
fun I burned down my library so you guys
think that the villains had come after
me too I orchestrated all these things
to basically take away your perspective
from mine at the same time you have you
have like Duke Thomas he's being
interviewed by the press and the cool
thing here is that Duke Thomas stands by
his perspective write it like he stands
by his beliefs the press kind of you
know pushes him and asked him and says
hey look do you regret the fact that you
teamed up with Jack Napier and his
answer is Jack maybe or screw up like
yeah he did some stupid things he wasn't
a hundred percent honest but if you were
a hundred percent honest like like I'd
be curious to see what we could find out
about you so at the end of the day his
whole stance is the only thing that
really matters to me is that when it
came down to it no one would come to
backport nobody would come to this
neighborhood and try to find a way to
make it better Jack Napier showed up
here and he showed up here without any
protection knowing he might die and his
message was I want to make that port a
better place and I want to extend this
improvement a back port to Gotham City
overall and so the result here is that
Duke Thomas basically says I would do it
all over again despite the mistakes that
he made it spite the mistakes of Jack
Napier made at the end the Gotham City
Police Department acknowledges the fact
that they basically ignored backward
they never send cops there then if there
was a crime in back port it was back
ports problem but now that everything
has sort of been put under a microscope
that everybody's looking into all these
different things the Gotham City Police
Department is correcting it and so it's
really a way to kind of find this
peaceful resolution to a part of the
city that really was in a lot of ways a
complete and total war zone and so what
we end up getting is this amazing
revelation we have Harley Quinn who's
sort of just on a bridge and I guess
enjoying the night or what-have-you and
Batman shows up and what Batman says is
that the pills that made Jack maybe your
same didn't come from nowhere Harley
Quinn was the one behind it the hold
hunt she's the one that made the pills
that made him st. and the whole reason
why was because she knew the Jack Napier
was there that there was an actual good
side to the Joker all that needed to
happen was that it needed to be brought
out and so she orchestrated it at all
she fed the pills and she she gave the
pills to the Joker knowing that he would
take them eventually because the Jack
Napier persona as weak as it was at the
time would find a way to make it happen
she knew the Joker which heiser that
Batman would chase after the Joker she
knew the Batman was dangerous did he had
a reckless disregard for life in Gotham
City or at least that's how people would
see it and so what she ended up doing
was following the two of them so that
when that conflict at the beginning of
the story happened and Batman and Joker
got into a fight and Batman beat the
crap out of the Joker then she recorded
the whole thing and she released it to
the Internet she set all this in motion
and it was like wow it was one of the
coolest reveals and and what we end up
learning isn't like Jack Napier figured
that out a long time ago and each hold
Batman what was going on but Batman
always stayed hands off because Jack
Napier asked him to but when the
question is asked why did you do this
like why did you orchestrate this entire
situation Harley Quinn's answer isn't
about love Gotham City was going to hell
in a handbasket you guys didn't care
about what happened but all you cared
about was finding the Joker and all the
Joker cared about was was you chasing
him it's the only thing that ever
mattered to you guys all the villains
who were there the penguin and two-face
and the Riddler and poison ivy all these
villains that you happen to face off
against they were just filler
until then next Alexis kurma SH with the
Joker it's what you lived for but
because of the fact that you gave so
little disregard to what was going on
here no one really looked at the bigger
picture no one ever had a reason to and
so because that Harley Quinn's like you
guys were killing the city on a
multitude of levels somebody had to step
in and somebody had to basically take
the two of you and force you to find a
middle ground and look at the bigger
picture and so again when the question
is asked would you do it again
Harley's answers abso
lutely of course I would do it again
there was never a time when I wouldn't
do it again it's made Gotham City a
better place it's made Gotham City
inherently better and so what is up
happening here is you basically have
Bruce Wayne Batman approaching Jim
Gordon and this is so cool because what
he does is he extends an olive branch
the idea of there being a barrier
between like Batman to bat family and
like the Gotham police department that's
being removed
Batman basically gives them the keys to
the Batmobiles lets us have Adam I
should have shared my technology with
you a long time ago I should have told
you guys what I was capable of I should
have given you guys the resources to
protect Gotham City and that makes sense
to me it makes sense that it's one thing
for Batman to be a one-man army it's
another for him to give people the
ability to protect themselves and so
because of that when he passes this
whole thing down at the end of the day
there's still the barrier of well why
should we trust you and it's cool
because what Batman says is like I
always wear a mask but I don't know why
I don't know if I wear the mask because
I secure myself I don't know if I wear
the mask because it's designed to scare
people and and this is what's so cool
about this is you could make an argument
for this on the surface looking at
Batman his crusade is rooted in the fact
that his parents died he doesn't want
anybody in Gotham to experience the same
thing but that motivation only runs so
deep it's Shawn Murphy's ability to kind
of add in this added explanation of why
Bruce Wayne's been going on for so long
when he says I just enjoy hurting
criminals the darker part of me actually
wants to kill people I want to kill the
Joker I want to kill two-face like I
want to I want to get rid of these guys
but the part of me that recognizes that
I would cross the line that I can't come
back from doesn't want me to and so it
was kind of like this the idea that
everyone even Batman himself has a Jack
Napier and a Joker and so what is it
happening as he says I've come to this
realization that the only way you guys
are ever going to trust me is to know
that I am a man and so what he does is
he says I'm going to reveal my identity
to you right now which is Bruce Wayne
and then I'm gonna go out publicly and
I'm gonna reveal my identity as Bruce
Wayne to the rest of Gotham City but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain it make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah one heck of a ride I love
that and the white knives is amazing
story but uh yeah guys I will catch you
all later
peace
[Music]